Congresswoman Nancy Pelosi will no
longer be in leadership she is currently
the Speaker of the House that
speakership is set to end when
Republicans take control of the house in
January of 2023 and Nancy Pelosi
announced on the floor of the house
yesterday she is not going to be seeking
a leadership role but she will be
staying in Congress the Associated Press
reporting that this is a quote pivotal
realignment making way for a new
generation of leaders Nancy Pelosi gave
a speech she said that uh first of all
she has led democrats for nearly 20
years secondly she is dealing with the
aftermath of this brutal attack on her
husband Paul Pelosi last month in the
San Francisco home she was the first
female speaker of the house and she will
not seek any leadership role starting in
January she says we must move boldly
into the future I will not seek
re-election to Democratic Leadership in
the next Congress for me the hour is
come for a new generation to lead the
Democratic caucus that I so deeply
respect she received a standing ovation
and it is not typical that a party
leader stays on after withdrawing from
the leadership she was re-elected and
there is much speculation about whether
this will be her final two-year term she
is 82 years old
um we don't know the answer to that but
Nancy Pelosi made it clear and it is
horrifying when you are influenced in
your plans
by such a horrifying attack like what
happened to Paul Pelosi because to some
degree you feel as though you're I'm
letting them push me out but there were
already questions about Nancy Pelosi's
future
whatever you think about her politics
and I am to Nancy Pelosi's left
you have to recognize not only the
significance as the first female speaker
of the house but her 20-year tenure in
Democratic Leadership
and her ability to get things done
they're not necessarily the most
exciting things always they're not
necessarily the things I would
prioritize but she did understand how
the House of Representatives worked and
while I have taken issue with Nancy
Pelosi so many times on specifics
um quite a career quite a career so
Nancy Pelosi stepping down from
leadership will stay in the House of
Representatives
I love cooking at home I cook all the
time having a good set of knives that
you actually like to use is really
important for years I have been a fan of
the advantages that Japanese knives
offer and our sponsor kamikodo makes
amazing Japanese steel kitchen knives
using the traditional techniques that
date back to the Edo period of Japan
kamikoto only uses steel from Japan each
blade takes years to craft and goes
through a rigorous 19-step inspection
process with a lifetime guarantee the
knives come in a beautiful heavy duty
Ash wood box makes it a really great
gift easy to store as well on the
kamikota website you can see a map of
the Michelin star chefs all over the
world using kamikoto knives my kamikoto
knives at home have been performing
great for years you really just can't
beat the feel of a nice Japanese knife
perfectly balanced in your hand and
kamikoto is now running a big Black
Friday sale my audience gets an extra
fifty dollars off go to kamikodo.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below